So today we're going to start analyzing
games.
So in my view this is where things start
getting a lot more interesting. So far
we've just said how to set up a game or
first how to set up an individual
decision problem and then how to set up
or represent a game and now we're
actually going to start thinking about
analyzing the game and trying to make
predictions about how people will play
in the game.
So I want to first go over
the approach that we're usually going to
take in this course.
We'll usually start with some informal
description of a strategic setting that
may be something that you get in a
problem set or um from thinking about
the world.
Then based on the informal description,
we'll usually write down the extensive
form representation.
Remember this is the very detailed
representation that we talked about a
lot on Tuesday.
And then we'll
reduce this extensive form
representation to the strategic form
representation.
And later on in the course we will
discuss some issues that can only be
perceived in the extensive form
representation, but for the beginning of
the course and in particular in today
everything we're going to say is going
to be about a strategic form
representation. So today our starting
point
is going to be three. We're going to
imagine that we're given a strategic
form game, but you can imagine in the
background that we may have derived this
given strategic form game from an
extensive form that we previously wrote
down.
So let's just recall the notation
for a strategic form game. We have the
players
I equals one through n
and then for each player I we have a
strategy set associated with that player
I. So we have big S1
up to big SN
where S1 is the set of strategies that
are available to player one. Remember
the set can be quite complicated if
we've derived this set by evaluating all
complete contingent plans in the
extensive form representation.
And then we have our payoffs
UI from S to R
where remember S is the set of strategy
profiles.
So S mathematically is a product set of
S1 up to SN, but the key thing is that
what lives in S are profiles specifying
a strategy for each of the N players.
And we have a function like this again
for each of the N players
that specifies each player I's utility
as a function of the profile of
strategies that the players play.
Now
what is our goal
when we analyze a game?
I think we're asking the following
fundamental question.
Given a game, we want to ask how do we
think players will play or should play
the game?
Now notice
I I think the distinction between will
play and should play gets into two
different interpretations of the
analysis that we do.
So the answers that we get and the
formal analysis we do won't really
depend on which interpretation you want
to keep in mind, but depending on the
application one may be more or less
compelling. So will play, if we want to
think about will play, this is what's
sometimes called positive analysis
or descriptive analysis.
And the idea of this is that if we
observe some game
we want to be able to make a prediction
about how rational players will choose
to play this game.
So the goal here is really a prediction.
Which will of course only be valid if we
think that the utility functions that we
write down and the rationality
assumptions that we make are compelling.
Another interpretation of game theory is
to kind of put yourself in the role of
an advisor.
Someone comes to you and says, how
should I play in this game? What is your
recommendation for how I should play?
And companies do sometimes hire game
theorists to consult and make
recommendations for maybe how they
should bid in an auction. That would be
one example. So here this is sometimes
called normative
or prescriptive
analysis.
And the goal of our analysis is to
provide what I might say is a
recommendation
for how players should play
uh
if they want to achieve their objectives
and they recognize that other players
are rational as well and maybe also are
getting advice from game theorists or
from other informed parties about how
they should play in the game.
But I just want you to keep this in mind
in the background throughout the course,
but when you're formally asked to solve
for an equilibrium or to analyze a game,
you're not uh
your answer won't really depend on your
particular interpretation in that
context.
Um so I want to start with
an example of a game
an example of a strategic form game and
this is the most famous game in game
theory probably. You may have heard of
it. It's called the prisoner's dilemma.
Now the first thing I want to write down
is think about how we can represent this
game.
It's kind of ugly to think about all
these functions and all these sets. So
normally we represent strategic form
games using what's called a bi-matrix,
just a box with some numbers in it.
So in this game each player
is going to have two strategies which
we'll call M and F.
So let me tell the story here. So we
have two prisoners.
And
we assume that they're placed in
separate cells. Again, this is going to
be a colorful story to help motivate
this particular game, but the lessons
from this game
I think a lot of game theorists and
economists believe are much broader than
this kind of silly uh story that we're
going to tell here.
So we have two prisoner prisoners and
they've been accused of a crime.
And each prisoner has two options.
We'll call them M and F.
So M is to stay mum.
That is don't admit to anything.
And F is sometimes uh the word is used
fink or tattle. It's to tell on the
other person. Say yeah, the other guy
did it.
So the the prosecutor comes by and says,
you know, do you want to uh accuse your
co-conspirator of committing the crime?
And the and the prosecutor says, look,
we'll give you a good deal. So if you're
willing to testify
against the other prisoner
we'll give you a sentence reduction. But
now we're going to be able to catch the
other guy and the other guy is going to
get a bigger sentence.
So now what we want to do is fill in the
payoffs in this matrix.
And what we imagine is
if both players stay silent
then both players get a payoff of two.
They both get convicted of say a minor
crime because they didn't have testimony
to convict either of them.
Now let's say I'm player one.
So the way I'm I'm writing this here is
player one
is the column is the sorry, the row
player. Player one is choosing
the row, so they're choosing between M
and F.
Player two is the column player.
They're choosing between the column M
and F.
So the strategy set, maybe this is
helpful here, for each player S1 equals
S2 equals M comma F.
So if we want to formally connect it to
our
strategic form representation over here,
each player has two strategies. They
each have the same two strategies,
simply staying silent M or uh testifying
against the other player, finking F.
And then when we write two two in this
box, the first number represents player
one's utility from this strategy profile
corresponding to this box. So this first
box corresponds to the strategy profile
where player one chooses M and player
two chooses M.
And then in the box we're writing player
one's payoff from that consequence or
that strategy profile and then player
two's payoff from that strategy profile.
Now let's go down here. We want to say
what happens if player one instead
testifies or finks against the other
prisoner.
What this should do is it could should
increase the utility of the prisoner who
finks because that prisoner gets a
sentence reduction.
But it decreases the utility of the
other prisoner because the other
prisoner is now going to be convicted of
a more serious crime.
So the exact numbers we'll use are three
and negative one.
So relative to the case where they both
stay silent, if I fink on the other
prisoner, my utility goes up by one
utile
but my opponent's utility goes down by
three utiles.
And now we're going to put the symmetric
payoffs over here.
But remember over here it's prisoner two
who's testifying and therefore prisoner
two gets the higher payoff and prisoner
one gets the lower payoff. So, here
we're going to put -1 3 in this box.
And then finally, we have to decide what
happens if they both testify,
and here the payoff is 0 0.
So, the exact numbers aren't so
important, but the order is pretty
important. So, why is it zero here?
Well,
uh
the other person is testifying against
me,
so I get convicted of a pretty serious
crime,
but it's not quite as bad as the -1 over
here, because I still get a little bit
of a sentence reduction for testifying
against the other guy.
So, you can see there's an ordering
between the four outcomes, and this is
REALLY WHAT'S IMPORTANT.
SO, THE HIGHEST PAYOFF I get is if I
testify and the other guy doesn't.
The worst payoff is if the other
prisoner testifies and I don't, because
then I get convicted and I don't get any
sentence reduction.
And then in between, we have the payoff
where we both stay silent, because we
only get uh charged with a pretty uh
small crime. And then the zero here is
where we both testify, we both get
charged with a serious crime, but we get
a little sentence reduction because we
each cooperate
with the authorities.
Now, I guess the question is,
how would you play
in this game? If you were here, you're
one of the prisoners, you're alone in
your cell,
how would you think about this and how
would you expect the other person
to play?
Say again?
You would go F? Okay, tell me why.
Cuz if the other one doesn't,
uh then you're just
in a very bad situation.
So, you're saying
uh
you want to go F because you're really
afraid of So, let's let's say you're
player one, okay? So, you're going to
say if I go F,
you're saying, well, I can either get
three or zero, but I'm at least not
going to get -1. So, that's that's good.
So, certainly the worst possible outcome
is better if I go F.
Um
I think F is a good strategy. Any other
thoughts about why I might want to go F?
Yeah. Regardless of what the other
player chooses, you're better off.
Right. So, this is a really critical
observation to make in this game.
So, I'm player one.
I don't know whether the other prisoner
is going to mum or fink. I don't know if
they're going to testify against me. But
let me reason separately by cases, okay?
One possibility
is the other prisoner is going to stay
silent.
If the other prisoner stays silent,
well, what happens? Either I get a
payoff of two if I stay silent, or I get
a payoff of three if I testify.
So, I'm better off testifying.
Now, let's look at the other case. What
if the other prisoner is going to
testify against me? That's certainly
worse for me. I'm certainly worse off.
But if the other prisoner testifies,
well, if I stay silent, I get -1,
and if I fink, I get zero, which is
higher.
So, in both cases, I do strictly better
if I fink. So, often we think that a
prediction of this game
might be we might be pretty confident
that
uh
for each player,
what are we saying? Well, F
is better than M,
no matter what the other player does.
And in a sense, games like this are
about a bit easier to analyze, because
remember we said what makes game theory
hard is what we called strategic
interdependence,
where the best thing for me to do
depends on what my the other player
does.
In this case, it is an interactive
problem, but the best thing for me to do
is independent of what my opponent does.
So, there actually is not this element
of strategic interdependence.
F is better than M if my opponent plays
M,
and F is still better than M if my
opponent plays F.
So, I don't really have to think too
carefully about exactly how my opponent
is going to play, because however I they
play, I know I'm better off
if I play F.
So, why is this called a dilemma, or
sometimes people think of it as a
paradox? Well, if both players play F,
then I don't know if I have chalk, but
I'll just highlight this.
We both get a payoff of zero.
But I think it's reasonable for someone
to come along and say, "Wait a second,
these prisoners must be doing something
wrong.
They're both getting a payoff of zero.
But if they did both did M,
they'd both be strictly better off.
So, are they being irrational? Are they
doing something wrong in this game? What
do you think? I mean, why is this a good
prediction of the game? We said we're
studying game theory. We said people are
very rational. They act towards their
objectives. And if they both do this,
they're both strictly better off. So,
why don't they do that?
Is something wrong with game theory?
Yeah?
They don't uh one player doesn't know
what the other player is going to do.
So, they're just operating in like just
maximize my utility
uh independent of what the other person
chooses. Right. Uh and another way of
saying it is I can't influence what the
other person chooses. So, when I framed
it, I sort of said, "Oh, we're down
here. Wouldn't we like to be up here?"
But how do we get up here? Well, both
players would have to behave
differently. And I can't control what
the other person does. I can only
control what I do.
And I think this observation
was surprising to a lot of people early
on. I mean, mathematically, it's not
very deep, but it definitely surprised
people.
And the
uh I think the key interpretation of the
prisoner's dilemma, or what we learn
from it, is that
in games,
rational behavior
can lead to inefficiency.
Or more precisely, rational behavior
can make everyone worse off.
What do I worse off than what, you might
say? Well, what I mean is than some
other behavior.
And this is a novel implication or a
novel feature of interactive
decision-making.
In a single decision-maker problem, this
never happens. In a single agent
problem, I just do what's best for me,
and that gives me the best possible
outcome.
But with an interactive problem, even if
we're both behaving
rationally, the outcome may be very bad
for both of us, and maybe worse than a
different outcome that would be feasible
for both of us.
>> [snorts]
>> So, I think today we want to continue
what we started here,
and
we argued that this game was relatively
easy to analyze because of this property
that the best thing for me is
independent of what the other player
does.
And I think that's a guide for the way
we're going to approach analysis in this
class. So, moving forward,
we're going to start with minimal
assumptions.
Minimal assumptions about behavior.
And because these are minimal or weak
assumptions, we're going to be quite
confident in the implications of these
assumptions. So, this might make us
confident about predictions.
But what we'll see is that a lot of
games are not like the prisoner's
dilemma,
and we're not able to make very sharp
predictions only based on minimal
assumptions. So, we might be confident
about our predictions, but these
predictions are generally going to be
very weak predictions.
Or they could be very weak predictions.
And here notice I'm I'm using the
interpretation of prediction rather than
recommendation for now.
In fact, sometimes if we're only willing
to make minimal assumptions about
behavior, our only prediction might be
anything could happen.
That's not a very useful prediction. We
might not be able to narrow things down
very much.
So, what we want to do is over the
course of the of the class is gradually
strengthen the assumptions that we make
about behavior. We might gradually lose
some confidence in the accuracy of these
predictions, but at the same time we'll
be able to sharpen and refine the
predictions that we make. And that's
kind of the direction we're going to go.
So, today we're going to start with what
I think of as the most basic or most
minimal assumption about behavior, and
later on we'll we'll move to more
complicated assumptions.
So, the first thing I need to do is just
introduce some notation for strategic
form games,
and then I can formally define
and capture what we described in this
game.
So,
strategic form games often have many
players, but we're often interested in
what happens when a single player
modifies their behavior, modifies their
strategy. So, we'd like to have some
notation to capture that.
And what we're GOING TO WRITE
IS
A STRATEGY PROFILE, WE'LL often
decompose it in this way.
So, we'll say we can think of the
profile as player i's strategy,
and s-i specifies the strategies of
everyone else.
And this notation is important, so let's
just go through an example with three
players.
If S equals S1, S2, S3,
this strategy profile specifies a
strategy for each of the three players.
But there's three different ways we can
express this depending on which player
we want to focus on.
So, we could write this as S1 S-1
meaning we're going to put player one
strategy by itself and then we're going
to group the other two players' strategy
under this notation S-1.
Here -1 is not really the number -1.
What we mean is not player one. So,
think of the the minus here as not
rather than minus.
But then there's another way we could
write this. We could write it as S2 S-2
or as S3 S-3.
And you might object that well, S3 is
supposed to come last. We're not really
going to be consistent about the order.
As long as we understand what this
means,
this is a
strategy profile where player three
chooses S3 and players one and two
collectively choose S-3. It's just
notation, but it's going to help us
write things down more more clearly.
Yeah.
Sorry, I I don't mean that. Uh
I don't I'm not making any just
notation, no behavioral assumption. So,
I literally when I write S-3, what I
mean is S1 S2.
It's just just kind of notation. So, I'm
not claiming that they're going to
decide together or I'm not doing
anything like that. So, it's just to
save space in the board instead of
writing S1 S2, I'm going to write S-3,
but they're still choosing independently
of each other. That's a good
clarification. Thank you.
And then we need some notation for where
these things live. So, we're going to
use notation where we've already
introduced SI,
but now we're going to use S-I to be the
set of you might call them partial
strategy profiles, right? These are the
set of profiles specifying a strategy
for every player except player I.
So, S little I lives in S big I
and S-I or not I lives in S not I. So,
that notation will be useful below.
Okay.
So, now we'd like to formalize what
happened in the prisoner's dilemma and
the formal term for this is dominance.
Sort of a natural term because F is
better than M no matter what the other
player does, we would say that strategy
F dominates strategy M.
But we have to be a lit- a little more
careful because there's strict and weak
dominance. So, now I'm going to define
these two terms.
So,
for player I,
so let's consider player I and let's
consider
uh two strategies.
SI and SI prime.
And I want to say so, I'm focusing on
player I.
I'm focusing on
two strategies. They could be the same,
but two strategies of player I.
This is a prime here.
And I want to formally define what it
means for strategy SI
to strictly dominate strategy S-I.
So, I'm going to say SI
strictly dominates
Ah, sorry. I may have said S-I. I mean
SI prime. Sorry.
Can you in guess in words strict
dominates what that might mean just to
re- think through from the example what
it might mean for player I if strategy
SI strictly dominates SI prime?
Uh
maybe at the back. Yeah. Uh they have a
better payoff regardless of S-I. Exactly
right. So, and by better it's strictly
better, right? So, SI dominates SI prime
means
Sometimes I'll use this arrow just to
mean a definition. So, I'm saying this
is exactly what this phrase means.
It means that
Well, let me first just partially write
it out.
So,
I'm going to fill it in a second,
but the first thing is I'm looking Let's
just focus on what's here already.
I'm focusing on player I
and player I is making a comparison
between things that are in player I's
control.
Player I is comparing
what happens if she plays SI
to what happens if she plays SI prime.
But what we want to argue is that this
inequality holds
whatever the opponents play.
So, we're going to fill in S-I here and
S-I here and we want this to hold for
all
S-I
in S-I.
So, notice the key point here.
S-I can take any possible value,
but in the inequality, the same S-I
appears on both sides.
So, fixing the way that my opponent is
playing, I'm strictly preferred to play
SI to play SI to playing SI prime.
Why do we write it this way? Because S-I
is outside my control. I can't control
what my opponents are doing, but they're
doing something.
So, how however they're behaving, this
inequality should hold.
Now, we want to give a slightly weaker
version of this. This is very demanding
and it may not hold. So, let's now say
weakly dominates.
I won't fill out everything else, but
you know, just copy these words.
And now we're going to weaken this to
weak inequality.
But
this is a little too weak because this
allows these two strategies to give me
the same payoff whatever my opponents
do. And we want there to be some reason
that SI is better than SI prime. So, we
demand this weak inequality for every
S-I,
but strict inequality
for some S-I.
So, however my opponents play,
SI does weakly better than SI prime,
but there's some at least one particular
way my opponents could play
such that SI does strictly better
than SI prime.
And in particular, the strict part of it
means that no strategy can weakly
dominate itself.
Because if we put the same strategy here
for SI and SI prime, then we would never
get a strict inequality.
So, so far these definitions have been
pairwise comparisons. We've taken one
strategy and we've compared it to
another strategy.
But in reality, the player just needs to
choose one strategy. So, what we'd like
to know is when is one strategy kind of
better than everything else or dominates
everything else. So, we'll say a
strategy SI
is weakly dominant
do weekly or strictly.
SI is weakly dominant if SI weakly or
strictly dominates every other strategy
that player I has.
So, maybe I'll just do weekly to avoid
confusion.
We say SI is weakly dominant
if
SI
weakly dominates
every strategy
SI prime. Now, I need to be a little
careful. There's something wrong here.
I can't say every strategy because SI
can't dominate itself, right? So, every
strategy SI prime that's not equal to
SI.
>> [clears throat]
>> So, we think that in this case,
if player I has a weakly dominant
strategy, that's a pretty safe
prediction about how that player will
play in the game, about which strategy
that player will use.
And we have one final definition.
And that is well, let's think about kind
of the simplest possible case. That's
where every player
has some dominant strategy.
Has some weakly dominant strategy.
If that's the case, then we can be
pretty confident our prediction in that
game is that each player is going to
play their corresponding weakly dominant
strategy.
So, we can give a definition here, our
first notion of an equilibrium.
We say a profile
S1 star
up to SN star
is a dominant strategy equilibrium
And here I'm just going to write
dominant strategy equilibrium, but
more precisely we mean weakly dominant
strategy equilibrium, but we'll just say
dominant and sometimes we'll call this
DSE.
If what?
Well, this is a profile, so we basically
made a prediction about how each player
in the game is going to play. We've made
a prediction about each player's
strategy.
And we say that this is a dominant
strategy equilibrium if each player is
playing a strategy that's a weakly
dominant strategy for that player.
So, if
for each player I,
strategy
Well, what is the strategy used by
player I? It's SI star. So, strategy SI
star
is weakly dominant.
But notice an important thing here that
when we make a prediction
about a game, it's not enough just to
predict one player's strategy. We have
to make a prediction about how every
player is going to play.
So our prediction here is a profile of
strategies specifying a strategy for
each of the end players.
And it's a dominant strategy equilibrium
if each player
for each player their strategy is weekly
dominant for them. Meaning that strategy
SI star, if we go back to our
definition,
SI star weekly dominates every other
strategy by player I.
Any question on this? Yes.
Is it possible to have like
um
like multiple weekly dominant strategies
that one is better than a different one?
That's a great question. So let's put
this here. Let's write this on the board
cuz I was going to get there. That's a
great question.
Is it possible for there to be multiple
weekly dominant strategies? So maybe
I'll say WD
strategies.
It's a great question.
Any ideas?
Put it to the class.
Yeah.
Say it again.
Okay.
Okay. So what you have in mind is what
if there's two strategies that give me
exactly the same payoff however my
opponent plays?
Now we have to be really careful.
The key thing though is this part of the
definition.
So if we didn't have this part of the
definition, we could have two weak we
could have two strategies that were both
weekly dominant because they both
because they give the same payoff
however the opponents play.
But two strategies that give the same
payoff are not going to satisfy strict
inequality for any way my opponents are
playing. So it's not possible for two
strategies for one strategy to weekly
dominate another and for that strategy
to weekly dominate the first. And for
that reason, it's impossible for there
to be multiple weekly dominant
strategies. So the answer is
is no.
Let's go through the argument again.
Suppose I had two strategies that were
both weekly dominant. Let's call them SA
and SB.
Well, that means SA must weekly dominate
SB.
And SB must weekly dominate SA.
But that means SB must do weekly better
than SA no matter how my opponents do,
but sometimes strictly better.
But if SB sometimes does strictly
better,
then it can't be the case that SA weekly
dominates SB.
Maybe a bit fast. It might be a good uh
little exercise to write down, but
that's a great question and uh it's good
to keep in mind and that's sort of our
one of our motivations for demanding
strict inequality for some S negative I
to rule out this case of multiple weekly
dominant strategies.
Great. Any other questions?
Yeah. Um just to clarify for the strict
inequality part for weekly dominance, is
it just that like the
um
you just have like the
UI
like that inequality part [snorts] is
strict?
Yeah. So So what I mean is let's list
for each S negative I, we have an
inequality that looks like this. So
let's say we have 10 of them and I'm
just going to go through each of them
and say does equality hold in every
single one of those inequalities? And
to get weak dominance, equality cannot
hold in every single one. So another way
of saying there must be one inequality
where it's strict, but it could be
equality in all but one. That's okay.
So when I say strict, I'm referring
to that being strict.
Great. Any other questions?
Okay.
So now let's look at a slightly more
complicated game than the prisoner's
dilemma
and see how we would approach this.
Make sure I got it.
Two on top. So we have a two-player
game.
So remember, we always put player one
here. Player one is always choosing
rows.
Player two is always choosing columns.
And when we fill in the payoffs, we
always put player one's payoffs first.
So here player one has three strategies.
We call them top, middle, and bottom
just to keep it make it easy to
remember.
And player two also has two strategies
which we call left and right.
So for what I'm going to do here, I
really only care about player one's
payoffs. So to avoid just distractions,
I'm only going to fill in
uh player one's payoffs.
So there should be something here. Maybe
I'll
put this to indicate if I wanted to
finish filling in the game, I'd have to
put in all those numbers. But for what
I'm doing now, I only care about these
first numbers.
So let's ask in this game,
does any strategy dominate any other?
Does it strictly dominate, weekly
dominate any other for player one?
What do you think?
How do you feel about this game? Are you
Would you be happy to play any of these
strategies or do you think some of them
seem worse than others?
Okay. Maybe we'll we'll go on, but the
answer is nothing dominates anything
else. Let's go through it. Does T
dominate M?
Well, you might think so cuz two is
greater than zero,
but over here we have negative one and
zero.
So M does better than T if my opponent
plays R.
So it can't be the case that T dominates
M.
And similarly, does M dominate B?
Well, even though M does better than B
when my opponent plays L,
M does worse than B when my opponent
plays R. And you can go through each of
these comparisons and see that no
strategy weekly dominates any other
strategy.
So now we have a bit of a conundrum. How
should you play in this game? It's not
so clear, right? Before it was pretty
easy. In the prisoner's dilemma, we said
if you're rational, play F. You don't
have to worry about your opponent.
However they play, you're strictly
better off playing F.
But here, it's not so clear. So how
would you approach this problem if you
were player one here? What would be
relevant to you? What would you need to
think about?
Yeah. You want to know like what the
chances are the other player plays L or
R. Exactly. So you're going to have to
form beliefs about how the other player
plays. Just like on the first class when
we said whether you you walk home or
take the T depends on after checking
your phone what you think the
probability is that it's going to rain.
In the same way, we're going to form
beliefs or assign probabilities to the
strategies that my opponent is playing.
So
in this context,
maybe we'll assign a probability of P to
L
and 1 minus P to R.
So now let's compute my payoffs.
Going to write U of
LP. So a few things here.
Because my opponent only has two
strategies,
if I want to specify my belief about
their strategy, it's enough to specify a
single number P. And I want to be clear
here. This is a number P. It's not a
vector, right? It's just a number. Once
I know how much probability I assign to
L, then the amount of probability I
assign to R is always just 1 minus that
probability. So this is enough
information.
And then here, remember technically
put one here. We only define the utility
U1 of a strategy profile.
So technically we haven't defined what
this means yet, but we're going to
extend our notation to define what my
expected payoff is if I play L
and I believe that my opponent is going
to play L with probability P and R with
probability 1 minus P. Yes. You wouldn't
be eating T or M or R is Ah, yes. T.
Sorry. Thank you.
T. Yes.
Great. Uh
So here we are. So what is it? Well,
with probability P, my opponent plays L
and therefore my payoff is U1
of TL.
But with probability 1 minus P,
my opponent plays R.
I'm still playing T. Thanks for the
clarification.
So we have T
R.
So notice we're treating my beliefs
about my opponent's strategy just like
we treated lotteries before.
When I have beliefs about something,
I
think about my choices as corresponding
to lotteries over outcomes and then I
evaluate expected utility over those
outcomes.
So here we can just plug in the numbers.
We're going to get this is going to be a
two and this is going to be a negative
one.
So
what do we get? We get 2P
minus one
plus P
if we do the math right,
which equals 3P
minus one.
And it's often good to to check if this
makes sense.
The higher is P,
yes.
So I just wanted to ask a future
question. The utility in this case is
specifically only the lottery which is
represented by the value two. So we also
have to include the strategy in there.
Right. So if you want to be a little
more formal, what is this? This is a
lottery Well, this is a two-player game.
So this is a lottery over the strategies
of my opponents. So this lives
in
delta of in this case S2, but more
generally S negative one.
Because what I need to do is I need to
say more generally of all the possible
profiles of strategies that my opponents
could play, I need to form a belief that
specifies the probability on each of
them. In this case, I can represent that
belief by a single number, but more
generally it's going to be a more
complicated object. So that means like
utilities are computed on the cross
product of strategies there.
Uh yes. Yes. And I'll I'll be more
formal in a second. Yeah. Um
other question, yeah?
Good point. Good point. People are being
very um very precise here. So, this is
sort of a you might say it's an abusive
notation or you might say we're
extending the notation on the right-hand
side. So, originally we defined
utilities only for strategy profiles.
And now we're going to define formally
what we're doing is we're going to
extend this function to a larger domain.
So, we're going to
imagine that it has the same meaning on
the original domain, but now we're going
to define it more broadly. Um so,
maybe if I was being very pedantic, I
would use different notation here, but
we're going to be a little less pedantic
and we're going to think of these
utilities as being defined uh on a bit
more general space. But, you're right
that conceptually there is a distinction
here. Though, one way to think about it
is
how do I interpret U1 of TL? One
interpretation is this is what happens
when I play T and I hold the belief that
my opponent is certain to play L. So,
you can think of this as a special case
where P equals 1. That would be one way
you can see how these functions fit
together. Yeah.
Any other questions? Yes. Can you choose
like big U on the left-hand side and the
little U on the right-hand side? Um I I
could do that. I'm not doing that here.
Uh I could do it, but eventually we just
find it easier to to always do this. So,
from now on we're going to use little U
and we can put in a belief or a strategy
over here. And if we put in a strategy,
the interpretation is that's a belief
that puts all the probability on that
particular strategy. Yeah.
Any other questions here?
Good. Okay. Um
and we could similarly compute I won't
do it here, but we could compute U1 of
MP
and U1 of BP.
Okay. And I guess the question suggested
we need to be a little more rigorous
about what these beliefs are and what we
mean. So, let me
bring this down and erase.
So, let's be a little more precise about
what a belief is.
Well, a belief for player I is just a
probability distribution over the
strategies that the other players are
playing.
So, I'll say for player I
it's a function
maybe we'll say beta negative I. We're
going to use the negative I because even
though it's the belief that's held by
player I, it's a belief about everyone
else's strategies. And that's why we use
the negative I here.
And what is it? Well, it's a function
from S negative I
to 01 if you want to be really formal.
Where it says
for each profile of strategies or
partial profile of strategies that my
opponents play
what is the probability that I assign to
that particular
profile of strategies? How likely is it
that they play that particular profile?
Now, what we need, you have to be
careful for this to make sense, when we
sum up all these probabilities, we have
to get one, right?
So, it's a function this like this
that's satisfying
what? Well, the total probability is
one, so let me take a summation. What am
I summing over? I'm summing over all the
partial strategy profiles of my
opponent.
So, I'm going to sum over S negative I
in big S negative I. If you're not used
to seeing summations that aren't just
numbers 1 to N, think of this as just
I'm writing out addition with
with one term for each strategy profile
S negative I.
And we have beta negative I of S
negative I
equals 1.
So, this is formally what a belief is.
And now let me formally define the
function that people rightly challenged
me on a little bit. So, if I want to
formally define extend this function,
we're going to define UI
of SI beta negative I. So, remember so
far we only defined player I's utility
from a strategy profile. Now, we're
going to think about what is player I's
expected utility
if player I plays strategy SI
and player I has holds this belief about
everyone else's strategies. Right? We're
going to take expectations.
So, we're going to need to do a
summation.
We always sum over things we don't know.
What we don't know is how my opponents
play.
So, this is going to be a sum over S
negative I in S negative I.
And we're taking an expectation, so I
want to for each way that my opponents
could play, I want to consider the
probability that happens, and then I
want to multiply that by the utility I
get if that does happen.
So, what's the probability
that
S negative I happens? It's beta negative
I of S negative I.
And I want to multiply this by the
utility I get if that happens. Well,
what's my utility? Well, I'm still
playing SI.
If it turns out my opponents play S
negative I, then my utility is UI
of SI S negative I.
Let me maybe draw a line here to make it
clear this is a separate point.
And this is the formal definition or the
formal extension of this function to
strategies and beliefs.
Now, we can also see here what we
mentioned earlier. What if beta negative
I is the special belief that puts
probability one on a particular strategy
of my opponents?
If that happens, then all of these terms
become zero except one of them.
And I simply get the same utility
function that I started with, where S
negative I is exactly the strategy that
my belief puts probability one on.
Any questions about this?
Yeah. So, in this case, just to confirm,
the left-hand side we have the cross
product
of all strategies, and then well, the UI
on the right-hand side is just
purely our strategy.
Exactly right. So, so this lives in
S.
And this lives in SI cross delta of S
negative I.
But, I don't want people to be scared by
the math, but yeah.
That's where where these things live.
Great.
Okay.
So, now we've talked about beliefs.
Now, we can talk about
a best response to a belief. And this is
I think one of the most central
ideas in game theory.
Mathematically, it's not very deep, but
conceptually it's really I think a step
forward. In interactive decision
problems, the idea is that there's two
steps. First, I form a belief about how
my opponents are going to play.
And then I choose a strategy that's best
given the belief that I form about
everyone else.
So, we want to formally define that.
So, we say
strategy
SI
is a best response
to belief
beta negative I. And remember, for any
of this to make sense, we have some game
in the background. Right? We have some
game in the background, we have some
player, and if I wanted to be really
precise, I would say
for player I, strategy SI is a best
response to belief beta negative I. Cuz
we're we're evaluating things here from
the perspective of player I.
Player I chooses a strategy for herself
and forms beliefs about everyone else's
strategy.
If Well, what's the What do we need?
Well, we want SI to do better than any
other strategy given the belief.
So, we need
UI of SI
So, what am I going I'll fill it in in a
second. I'm player I.
I'm comparing the utility that I get
from SI
to the utility I get from SI prime.
And I want SI to be better than SI prime
for any SI prime that I contemplate.
But, what goes in here? Well, what goes
in here is the fixed belief that I have.
So, this is beta negative I
and this is beta negative I.
So, given the belief beta negative I, I
can compute my expected utility from any
strategy.
And we say that strategy SI
is a best response to my belief if the
expected utility I get from SI is weakly
larger than the expected utility I get
from any other strategy SI prime.
Now, let's go back to the question that
was asked earlier. Can I have multiple
best responses to a belief?
Is that possible? Can two strategies
both be best responses to the same
belief?
Yes. So, this sort of goes back to the
suggestion before. If I had two
strategies SI and SI prime that gave me
exactly the same utility no matter what
my opponents did, then it's possible for
them both to be best responses. In fact,
they could both be best responses even
if they didn't give me exactly the same
utility, but the expected utility was
the same. So, um
let's note here.
There can be
multiple best responses
to the same belief.
If we wanted there to only be one, we
sometimes might use the phrase strict
best response to say this is a best
response and nothing else is a best
response. Uh but we'll generally just
use the weak sense.
Okay, let's try to
understand this graphically.
I think there's space.
Maybe let's do this over here. So, let
me
just erase this.
Yeah.
Yes, so delta is the space of lotteries
over the set. Yeah.
And let me actually just erase this to
get myself a bit more space.
So, let's try to understand best
responses in this game.
Best responses to what? Well, best
responses for player one to player two's
to to player one's belief about player
two's strategy.
So, what we want to do is we're going to
draw some payoffs here. So, I'm going to
put
I'm going to draw a graph here where on
the horizontal axis
I'm
Maybe it's better if I put P on R. So,
let me just
switch this so that we're geometrically
better.
So, I can describe my belief by my
probability on L or my probability on R.
It's more convenient to put it the
probability on R
because then the graph is going to move
left to right, and that's going to be a
bit better.
So, P down here is the probability on R.
And I'm going to draw this graph from
zero to one.
So, if P equals one, then I'm certain
that my opponent is playing R.
If P equals zero, then I'm certain that
my opponent is playing L.
And say if P is one half, then I think
it's equally likely that my opponent
plays L and that my opponent plays R.
You can see why I switched things that
we move from left to right I think is a
bit more intuitive.
>> [snorts]
>> Okay.
And now to think about best responses, I
basically want to plot each of these
functions.
I want to say, if I play T,
what is my utility from T as a function
of the belief that I have about my
opponents?
So, let's start.
Let's put -1, 0, 1, 2.
If I play T,
well, if my opponent plays L, I get a
payoff of two.
So, that means if I'm certain that my
opponent is going to play L,
if that's my belief, then my payoff
better be two.
So, we're going to get a point up here.
And if I'm certain that my opponent is
playing R, then I get a payoff of -1.
So, it better be
that we get a point like this.
And it turns out, we could calculate it,
but it turns out expected utilities are
always linear in my beliefs. So, once we
know these two points, we can just fill
it in.
It's going to be a line like this.
So, this is
U1
of T P.
And remember, if you did the formula
earlier in your notes, we've switched P
to 1 - P. So, the formula in your notes
was for the old convention.
So, that no longer applies.
What about B?
Well, B is kind of symmetric, right? If
I play B, then if I know my opponent is
playing left, I get -1.
And if I know my opponent is playing
right, I get two.
I'll test my drawing skills here.
And it's going to be linear.
So, we're going to get something like
this.
What about M? What is the graph of M
going to look like? It's going to look a
bit different, right?
What will that line look like? Yeah?
It's just a horizontal line at zero
because if I play M,
whatever my opponent does, I get a
payoff of zero. So, whatever I believe
my opponent's doing, I'm going to get a
payoff of zero.
So, now we have a horizontal line
here at zero. And if we're careful, this
intersection should be at one half.
You can check that.
Guys, let me finish writing these out.
So, to be clear, each of these is a
different function of P. We have three
different functions of P where P is a
number between zero and one. And I've
graphed all three of the functions here.
So, from the graph, we should be able to
say a lot about best responses.
Can anyone read off from the graph what
my best response is?
Let's go through it, right?
Let's fix a belief.
A belief is some point on the horizontal
axis, right? Now, once I fix that
belief, if I want to understand my
payoff from my different strategies, I'm
going to draw a vertical line upwards.
And as I pass up through that vertical
line, each curve I intersect is telling
me my expected payoff from that
particular strategy given this belief.
So, at this point, what it tells me is
my lowest payoff is from B.
M gives me my middle payoff.
And then T gives me the highest payoff.
So, at any beliefs where the highest
curve is T, T is my best response.
At any beliefs where B is the highest
curve, B is my best response.
So, let's look at this. Let me see, I
should have gotten out the colored
chalk.
It'd be nice if I had it.
Hmm, maybe no colored chalk today.
Ah, yes.
So, what I'm actually going to do, the
easiest thing to do is I'm going to
shade in what's sometimes called the
upper envelope. I'm going to go through
all these curves, and I'm going to look
at what's highest. So, if I'm here, this
is the highest curve.
Comes down.
Here it changes. Now this becomes the
highest curve, right?
I get something like this.
So, now
you can see down here.
Can anyone now read off from the graph
what my best responses are as a function
of my beliefs? So, when is T a best
response?
For which beliefs is T a best response?
Yeah? From zero to one half, probably
you choose R.
And then from one half to one, it's
going to be T. And then at
one half, you could play either. Great.
So, exactly right. And a And a key point
to make at the end, these are inclusive.
So, at half, I actually have two best
responses. T and B are both best
responses at a half as you pointed out.
And if my belief is below a half, then T
is the unique best response or the
strict best response.
And if P is above a half, then B is the
unique best response or the strict best
response.
Great. Does this make sense? Well, yes,
right? Because T does really well if my
opponent plays left.
So, if my probability on right is small
enough, and I think it's likely enough
that my opponent is playing left, then T
is the best option.
If it's likely enough that my opponent
is playing R,
then B is the best option, and we see
that B is the best response. Is a best
response.
But now we have sort of a
predicament, which is, what about M?
M is not a best response to any belief.
Does this mean we shouldn't play M? What
do you think about M?
Would you ever play it?
Yeah?
If you're super uncertain about your
beliefs, to be very risk averse to
picking one, you could consider M.
Okay, we have to be really careful with
those words. Um
What you're describing is something
important that we're not going to cover
in this class, which is called ambiguity
aversion. So,
um
I don't want to go too far down this
path, but um we're going to stick with
expected utility, and
uh risk aversion would not actually
cause you to choose M. Something called
ambiguity aversion would, but we're not
going to talk about that. So, we're
imagining that we have our beliefs well
defined about how the other person is
doing. Um So, I think it's actually fair
to say I don't really want to play M.
There's no belief against which M is a
best response.
But, I think it's natural to think back
to dominance, right?
What we said before is you might want to
throw out a strategy if it's dominated
by another strategy.
But now we're in this kind of weird
middle ground where a strategy M is not
a best response to any belief,
but it's also not dominated by any other
strategy.
And that is kind of a weird conundrum.
But we're going to show that in fact, M
is dominated. We just have to be a
little more careful. Can anyone see a
sense in which M is
dominated? Is there anything I could do
that would always do better than M?
Yeah? Like a mixed strategy that
basically varies on whatever P is. If P
is like
zero to one half, you just play T.
Otherwise, you play B. That strategy
dominates M.
Okay, so I like the first part of what
you said about a mixed strategy, but
crucially with a mixed strategy, we
can't vary our mixing probability based
on
our belief. But But the mixed idea is
crucial. So, what if I said, instead of
taking choosing strategy M, I'm going to
flip a coin. Do you want to add
something? Okay. Imagine I flipped a
coin,
and if the coin is heads, I'm going to
play T.
So, consider
the strategy which we'll call half T
plus half B.
What does this mean? I'm going to flip a
coin.
If it's heads, I play Well, if it's
heads, I play T, that's really weird. If
it's tails, I play T. If it's heads, I
play B. Okay?
If I were to do that,
let's let's add this strategy down here,
right? So, this is half T
plus half B.
If my opponent plays L,
what is my payoff from this mixed
strategy where I flip a coin?
It's my expected payoff. Well,
with probability half I play T
and I get two.
With probability half I play B and I get
negative one.
So, my expected payoff is half of two,
which is one,
plus half of negative one, which is
minus a half, and if I add it up I get
one half.
And now let's go to this side.
If I do my same coin flip,
with probability half, I'm going to get
negative one.
With probability half, I'm going to get
two.
So, maybe I'll do the addition here,
right? It's half
times two
plus half times negative one. It's kind
of easier to distribute and say, well,
two minus one is one, so it's half times
one, which is one half.
Well, now is M dominated?
So, in this case we see that M is not
dominated by any pure strategy, but it
is dominated by what's called a mixed
strategy. There's a way I can flip a
coin
so that if I flip a coin in this way,
well, if my opponent plays L, I get half
from this mixed strategy and I only get
zero from M.
And if my opponent plays R, I get half
from this mixed strategy and I only get
zero from M.
And in fact, whatever belief I have
about what however my opponents play, I
do strictly better under this mixture.
We could even write down the payoff of
this mixture. It's actually going to
look exactly like this.
If we wanted to say, what is my expected
payoff
from this mixed strategy as a function
of my belief? So, what I have here, let
me put it a bit separate, is U1
of half T
plus half B, comma P. So, this says, if
I believe my opponent is playing right
with probability P, and I flip a coin
and play T with probability half and B
with probability half, what is my payoff
going to be? And you can see the
dominance relation because this is
always higher than this.
So, do we think that people really play
mixed strategies in practice?
We can debate about it, but I want to
point out that this kind of resolves
this seeming paradox at first. Where on
the one hand M was never a best response
to any belief, so it seemed like a
really bad strategy, but we couldn't
directly show what would always be
better than it.
By using mixed strategies, we can. We
see that in fact M is dominated. It's in
fact strictly dominated, just not by a
pure strategy. It's strictly dominated
by a mixed strategy. So, let's formally
define a mixed strategy. It's sort of
what you would think, but um
I'm going to be careful.
So, what is a mixed strategy? It says,
well, just like a belief, it's a
probability distribution or a lottery,
but it's not a lottery about other
people's strategies, it's a lottery
about my own strategy, right? So, a
mixed strategy for player I
is a function
or is a probability distribution
We often use the notation sigma I. So,
we use SI for a pure strategy and sigma
I, it's like the Greek version of S, we
use that for a mixed strategy. Well, now
it's going to be a function from SI to
zero one
that says, for each possible strategy,
what is the probability that I play that
strategy? But once again, we need
another condition for this to make
sense. The probabilities have to sum up
to one, right? So, it's a function
satisfying
Well, if I sum over all my strategies,
the probability I put on that strategy,
that better sum to one.
And I asked before, do people ever play
mixed strategies? In a lot of economic
contexts, they don't, but there's
actually one domain where mixed
strategies are crucial. Does anyone know
what's the domain where
people are very careful to play mixed
strategies?
Or are there times where you've played a
mixed strategy?
Yeah.
Rock, paper, scissors is is a good one.
Um and if you played in rock, paper,
scissors competitions, yeah, that would
probably be really important. There's
another domain where people make a lot
of money that where randomization is
also important. Yeah. Poker.
Professional poker, right? So,
professional poker players are extremely
good at randomization and they train to
randomize well. Humans are very bad at
randomizing naturally and there's all
these techniques professional poker
players make. 15 years ago, you could
play poker and win money without being
good at randomizing. Today, you would
just get destroyed. Because the best
players are extremely good at
randomizing and they study game theory
and they randomize extremely carefully.
Uh and basically the people who are
better at randomizing with exactly the
right probabilities win a lot of money.
Um so, poker is a great example of mixed
strategies that really happen. If I
taught this course 20 years ago, it
would be hard to come up with an example
of people playing mixed strategies and
now the the sort of reality has caught
up to the game theory and now there's a
lot of people make a lot of money uh by
mixing.
Okay. So, now let's
move on a little bit and try to
understand how general this phenomenon
is. So, I want to make one observation
here and then we want to try to see how
general that is. So, if you're
approaching a game like this
and you're player one, there's kind of
two ways you could go about it. If I
were to ask you, what is a reasonable
strategy to play?
You could say, well,
so, let me say, let's look at player one
and I'll just say which strategies.
Well, one thing you could do is you
could start with the sort of the good
strategies, okay? And maybe I'll call
them the reasonable strategies.
This is not really a formal term, but
I'll just say reasonable strategies.
And these would be the strategies that
are best responses to some belief.
So, I don't want to think too much for
for the moment about how you form your
beliefs, but let's just say,
is there some belief I could have that
would make this a best response?
So, in this game, we saw in the graph
which strategies in this game are best
responses to some belief. So, which
strategies are reasonable in this sense?
Yeah.
T and B, right?
So, I might say, look,
I have three strategies, but the
reasonable ones are T and B, right?
Another way you could approach it though
is instead of looking for what you
should do, you could try to look for
what you don't want to do and avoid
that. So, I could say, what are the
unreasonable strategies?
And by an unreasonable strategy, I mean
a strategy that's strictly dominated
by some other strategy, possibly mixed.
Now, technically I only defined
dominance for pure strategies, but
everything makes sense if I just replace
the SIs with uh sigma Is and I interpret
these utilities as expected utilities.
So, in this game, what are the
unreasonable strategies? What are the
strategies I could throw out by saying
they're dominated by something else?
Yeah.
M. Just M, right?
So, notice here there's two different
ways to get to the same answer. I could
say, let me only consider strategies
that are best responses to some beliefs.
I would go through and I would just get
T and B.
Or I could kind of do the inverse. I
could say, let me throw out all the
strategies
that are dominated, that are strictly
dominated by something. I would throw
out M and I'd be left with just T and B.
And the question is, is this a
coincidence? Is this a special property
of this game? Or is this more generally
true that we can always split our
strategies into two groups?
Those that are best responses to some
belief and those that are strictly
dominated by some mixed strategy.
And it turns out this is a very general
property and that'll be sort of the
first theorem that we state in this
course.
So, let me
state the theorem.
So, here's our
theorem.
We need some assumptions, so let's say
we're in a finite strategic form game.
Finite just means the set of strategies
for every player is finite and there's
finitely many players.
So, for each player I
and each strategy SI
So, before I write it, let's just
understand. We fixed our finite
strategic form game.
We're considering a particular player I
and a particular strategy SI.
And what we want to argue, what we want
to say, is that this strategy
falls in exactly one of these two
categories.
It can't be in both
and it can't be in neither.
So, what we say is exactly one of the
following holds.
Exactly one means not both and not
neither.
And one is that this strategy SI is
reasonable in this sense.
Meaning what? SI is a best response to
some belief.
And when I say belief, what is that a
belief about? It's a belief
Maybe I'll say over
S negative I. Let's remind ourselves
when player I forms beliefs, they form
beliefs over the strategy profiles of
the other players.
And then the other case is SI is
strictly dominated.
By what? Well, by some mixed strategy
and we have to allow mixed. If we only
allowed pure strategies, we already saw
up here that the theorem wouldn't be
true because there are strategies that
are never best responses, but are not
dominated by any pure strategy. So, we
have to allow for mixed strategies.
SI is strictly dominated by some mixed
strategy.
And of course, when I say strategy, that
has to be a strategy of player I because
player I is compares two different
strategies when they look at strict
dominance. But wait a second, I said SI
is strictly dominated by some mixed
strategy. What about pure strategies?
Am I including those?
Why?
Exactly right. So, every pure strategy
is a mixed strategy
but not every mixed strategy is a pure
strategy.
So, as long as I cover mixed strategies,
in particular I'm including the mixtures
that put all the probability on a single
strategy which are simply pure
strategies.
So, if we want to say that I'm not doing
that, sometimes we say properly mixed
strategy or non-pure mixed strategy, but
here we're allowing
all kinds of mixed strategies including
the ones that are just pure strategies
in disguise.
And again, I think the interpretation of
this is that there are two
very natural ways of thinking about a
game and which strategy someone might
play. I think it'd be very natural to
say it's reasonable to play anything
that's a best response to some belief.
And it would also be natural to say
here's what you should do. Just don't
play anything that's strictly dominated
by something else.
And if those two approaches gave us
different answers, we have to really
think hard about which one was more
reasonable.
But it turns out these are literally
going to give us the same answer.
So, you can think positively about
what's the best response to something
or you can think negatively about what's
strictly dominated by something
and either way, you're going to get the
same two groups of strategies, the good
ones and the bad ones.
Um let me say a little bit about how we
prove this.
The proof won't be
covered on exams, but I want to
give some idea.
So, what's the argument?
Proof.
Well, how do you show that exactly one
thing happens?
You have to show that both can't happen
and neither can't happen. So, another
way of saying it is
at most one
So, at most one of these two things can
be true
and at least one.
So, to say at most one of the statements
is true
is another way of saying both statements
can't be true.
Right? At most one, not two.
At least one
is a way of saying it can't be the case
that neither is true.
Right? At least one, either one or two,
but not two.
And by one or two, I mean
the number maybe I'll call these A and B
to avoid confusion.
I'm talking about at most one meaning
the number of statements that are true,
not the labels of the statements.
So, one of these directions is more is a
bit easier.
One of these is is quite tricky. Does
anyone see one that they think is kind
of intuitive and they could maybe
you know, I won't ask you for the proof,
but could kind of reason through on
their own?
Yeah.
At most one. So, this is the easier
direction, and not not easy maybe, but
easier. And what's your kind of
intuitive argument? I won't we won't
give a formal one, but um
We're going to get a contradiction,
right? So, if both were true, you're
saying this is the best we can do
against some belief but there's
something else that is strictly better
whatever my opponent does. Well, if it
does strictly better whatever my
opponent does it should also do strictly
better given my belief. But that means
the other thing couldn't be a best
response. So, I think it's pretty
intuitive. I'd encourage you to work out
the algebra on your on your own. I think
this is a good exercise to do at home.
Uh the at least one is a lot harder and
that I wouldn't expect you
to be able to figure out at home. There
is a proof given in the appendix of the
lecture notes. And actually, let me
clarify. I said I won't test you on the
proof, but I could test you on this part
of the proof. I think that's the top is
fair game, the bottom is not. Let me be
clear about that. Uh so, the bottom for
the harder part uh see appendix.
And it uses a mathematical result called
either the separating hyperplane theorem
which you may have heard of
or something called Farkas' lemma is
also my preferred way of proving it.
And just to see why this is harder well,
if SI we want to show at least one is
true. So, we have to say if SI is not a
best response to some belief then it's
strictly dominated by something.
But that means the proof requires you to
construct something and that's what's
hard. All we know is it's not a best
response to any belief but how do we
know what dominates it?
Well, how do we come up with that?
That's pretty hard. So, this theorem
gives you a way of constructing either
the belief you need or the
dominating strategy that you need and
that's that's much more involved, so
that won't be covered in the course, but
I encourage you to read the appendix if
you want to see that.
And uh let me stop there and I'll see
everyone next week. Good luck on the
quiz uh tomorrow.